it was before Dawn when Terror struck
the capital city
the residents of this nine-story block
were all still sleeping when the attack
happened
the apartments are next to a school and
playing fields there are no military
targets here
the explosion tore down the block
stairwell making the way out impossible
for some
fire Crews had to stretch a residence to
safety Russian officials have insisted
they're not targeting civilians but try
telling these people that
I was woken by this huge explosion and
everything in the room was on the floor
Windows the TV everything my television
had been smashed into the wall in front
of the window climbed out of the rubble
and then I saw my neighbors were also
alive they got out from my window
because they couldn't get out any other
way
this was a real step up in the Russian
attacks inside the capital
a terrifying development for its
residents many of whom have insisted
they'll fight to the end
yet more homes destroyed and shattered
lives packed into suitcases
but there's real anger too at What's
Happening Here
I'll kill Russians whenever I see them I
carried my mother out with my bare hands
she's 84 years old she was cut by glass
but she's alive for what you need to
close the skies
within the space of a morning the
capital had suffered several attacks
this was the Antonov aircraft plant
Ukraine's largest at this stage it
seemed to the city's residence they were
facing multiple strikes in Kiev as well
as heavy fighting on at least three
fronts in the city's suburbs
look at this CCTV
it's the city's third attack in ours
only a couple of miles from the district
hit earlier
the missile was intercepted by Ukraine's
air defenses but the debris showered
down on another heavily built up
residential area destroying a tram and
Taxi
devastating lives and homes and filling
residents with fear
the foreign I feel terrible he says and
then breaks down
he's full of rage and emotion
apologizes he can barely talk but tells
us this is the result of what he calls
the West's policy of appeasement
he means the rest of the world's
reluctance to get directly involved and
Ukrainian politicians insist hitting
homes is deliberate by the Russian
leader he can't he can't win at our army
our army is holding the ground so they
he started to fight with unarmed people
with pregnant women like in marupo with
children with just civilians who just
live so that's that's their genocide in
21st century in the middle of Europe
and this while peace negotiations are
ongoing to try to find a way out of this
but talk of ceasefires and Troop
withdrawals seem a very long way off
right now as residents pick through
their broken homes
they are going to extraordinary lengths
because many of their possessions and
everything they own are still in these
Flats so they're having to use the fire
trucks to get entrance
Russia's been accused of targeting
hospitals schools and homes for weeks
now attacking civilian areas and
non-competence is a war crime and
Ukrainian lawyers who are gathering
evidence say the Russian troops are also
specifically focusing on food supply
chains
[Music]
there's a bread factory very close to
here and they could have been trying to
attack the food supply chain for the
city it wouldn't have been the first
time
the tactic of surrounding cities
starving the citizens of supplies and
bombarding them with airstrikes is one
favored by the Russians they've used it
in Syria
now Ukraine and specifically Kiev is in
their sights but they didn't reckon on
this Defiance and patriotism
they have to know where strong he shouts
down the world probably knows that by
now Alex Crawford Sky News in Kiev